where do you live with Colossus owner
and spoon why the masks ugly why the
jokes insecure my Princess Bride I'm a
fan
why Celine Dion I'm a bigger fan why the
holidays thought it'd be fun my pg-13
it's a family movie also money also
Disney why do you think audiences will
be stupid enough to swallow this not
sure this level of curiosity is cute
coming from middle-aged man strapped to
a bed against his will one on timing not
on your life hey everybody is Charlie
happy holidays this is gonna be my Once
Upon a Deadpool post-credit scene video
for the new post-credit scenes that they
added they made some significant changes
to the original post-credit scenes from
deadpool 2 and then added a whole bunch
of new ones and then i'll do a bit of a
review at the end of the video since
it's the holidays will also do a new
round of that imax ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Deadpool moment on the video so like I
said they start out with the original
Deadpool to post-credit scenes with a
couple really big changes so he still
takes cables time-travel device from
Mako sonic teenage warhead and Yukio in
the mid-credits scene
so the mid-credits post-credits
mid-credits come right after all the
crayon drawing credits he goes back in
time to save Vanessa this time with some
of the blood and guts digitally removed
when he takes out Vanessa's would-be
killer with the kitchen utensil then
they added a new mid-credits scene with
Fred Savage like their Princess Bride
scenes that they shot fer to this cut of
the movie they talked about how much
they loved post-credit scenes about how
their private little talks with the
filmmakers they foreshadow a little bit
about how Deadpool will be a proper
Marvel character soon they make more
Marvel Foxx jokes and Fred Savage starts
calling him on a lot of [ __ ] that he
saw during the film and he makes fun of
the fact that they made a pg-13 cut of
Deadpool in the first place double
dipping because they just released two
separate cuts of the film from Marvel
movies we are Marvel yeah you know your
Marvel license by Fox it's like if the
Beatles were produced by Nickelback its
music it sucks okay that's it I'm done
I've had it with all this Nickelback
hating alright you think that makes you
cool with the cool kids in school Fred
now just makes me write it does it
they're over produced formulaic ear
garbage they also use Fred Savage to
acknowledge some of people's biggest
complaints about Deadpool - after the
movie came out in theaters earlier this
year they subtly remind people that
there will
be more post-credit scenes after the
black and white credits because i
assumed that a lot of young families
went to see this so like little kids
would probably get up and leave it
wouldn't stick around for the credits
unless you told them to they played the
regular black and white credits and then
you go into the actual post credits from
the original Deadpool to film albeit cut
down in the same way that they cut down
the Vanessa scene so you get a version
of that Deadpool Wolverine Origins scene
with Hugh Jackman except they just cut
down the scene where Deadpool is killing
the Wolverine Origins version of
Deadpool to be way less bloody they do
the exact same thing for the Green
Lantern scene where Deadpool kills Ryan
Reynolds before he can sign his contract
except there's no blood splatter on the
page they didn't do the baby Hitler
scene because that was from the Deadpool
- super duper cut extended edition
blu-ray then they added a couple
additional post-credit scenes right at
the end so the last one is Fred Savage
being freed by Deadpool like he unfurls
the bed like you saw during the trailers
with a duct tape around his legs when he
gets up you notice a couple things one
his legs have atrophied like they want
to make the joke that he's been trapped
there for a long time so his legs are
like little spindly skeleton legs and
when Deadpool kidnapped him and put him
in the same shirt that he was wearing
from Princess Bride he did not put any
bottoms on him so they blur everything
on Fred Savage from the waist down
because he's buck-ass naked then they
break the fourth ball when Fred Savage
looks around sees all the camera crew
and they imply that the crew helped
Deadpool kidnap him and put him in that
bed then they go into a final Stanley
special memorial post-credit scene we
all wondered if they were gonna do some
special tribute they totally did it's
actually a couple of different things
together so you could say that there are
even more post-credit scenes they have a
couple funny moments of deleted scenes
from Stan Lee's cameos there was a Green
Lantern joke where he says that Deadpool
is supposed to be wearing a green suit
they do a photo montage of Stan Lee's
work throughout the years at Marvel
Comics and then there have an actual
scene with Stan Lee being interviewed by
someone who's asking him how he wants to
be remembered by people when he's gone
and started it
I dreamed up spider-man and the Hulk the
x-men all the others
[Music]
what I tried to do was take these
characters who are obviously bigger than
life and fictitious
and make them seem real they've got
these powers they do wonderful things
but what what are the things that worry
them what are the things that frustrate
them I tried to write a well-rounded
character with every character I did
rather than just somebody who is extra
strong and can beat up the bad guys he
wrote some good stories I don't think
about that much
you know when I'm gone I really don't
care it doesn't do any good when you
gone Stanley replies I hope they say he
wrote some good stories and then they
sort of end on that moment so it's less
of a funny moment and more of just like
honest memorial to Stanley so it is
really nice hopefully at some point
they'll post that online I don't know if
they have plans to make an actual
blu-ray cut like a separate cut of the
film of this once upon a Deadpool or
what they're gonna do with the
additional material they shot in terms
of my actual review of the film I'm not
quite as harsh on it as some of the
other reviewers that I've seen because
it's definitely a double-dip like I said
if you saw a Deadpool 2 or if you
already owned the blu-ray of the super
duper cut with all the extra material in
it there's not really a compelling
reason for you to spend an extra fifteen
or twenty dollars or whatever it does
cost where you live to actually go to
the theaters see movies it was fun
seeing them do all the Fred Savage stuff
he was definitely a champ and they did
write some good material there were some
reports that they shot most of these
scenes with him in less than a week like
I've seen varying reports of how long
they actually spent doing this new stuff
but it just didn't feel quite big enough
for a theatrical release like this felt
like something that they would do for a
cable like if it was on a major network
like oh we can't show Deadpool being
quite as graphic so we got to find a
funny way to make it entertaining then
you do something like this
I don't think audiences will be quite as
forgiving in the future if they continue
to do this multiple cut situation like
obviously we all expect an extended cut
on blu-ray like that's always nice just
cram some extra deleted scenes in there
but when you're talking about theatrical
like either just released one cut of the
film or to the other like is it gonna be
pg-13 is it gonna be our just pick one
go with it then maybe just add a whole
bunch of material on the blu-ray when
you release that so we give them an A
for intentions but like a B maybe
b-minus for execution but like Deadpool
jokes one of the reasons why they did
this pg-13 cut like in addition to
raising money for a charity and doing
something nice for families is just like
a brief stunt they also did it a little
bit because of the upcoming deal with
Disney and a lot of people are just
wondering what's gonna happen with the
Deadpool franchise when they're
underneath Disney will it be the same
Deadpool will they make them go pg-13
the CEO of Disney said that they were
really excited about the Deadpool
franchise but he didn't give many
specifics so I'll believe it when I see
it so if they say that they're not gonna
do anything with Deadpool to completely
change the character that's great so
getting ready to start making the next
Deadpool movie so we'll find out pretty
quickly I do think that they can make a
good Deadpool pg-13 movie but here's the
really important thing they have to
start out planning it that way they
can't make an r-rated film and then just
cut it down to a pg-13 film that's not
the same thing like Ryan Reynolds is
good at what he does they can find good
writers to make a funny movie in a way
that parodies a lot of the tropes of
Marvel films they'll have all the MCU
characters to work with so they can't
air Iron Man in the Avengers a new one
they can have a lot of fun with that but
they just have to plan it to be that way
from the start so whatever they're gonna
do I just hope that they figure it out
and it'd be nice if they told us
sometimes you don't find out to the end
of the game like we thought that venom
was gonna be rated R they said that they
were trying to make a rated R film then
later Double Down and said no no no we
always planned on doing pg-13 when very
clearly that is not the case so if you
had a chance to see Once Upon a Deadpool
in theaters let me know what you thought
about it and the idea of a pg-13
Deadpool movie so I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
click here from my Aquaman post-credit
scene video and click here for that new
Captain Marvel Avengers endgame clip
thank you so much for watching happy
holidays everyone I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]